en este vídeo quiero platicar acerca del
plan de ahorro para el retiro ir a
tradicional gira le voy a poner aquí
tradicional tradicional gira son siglas
en inglés para individual retirement
account individual retirement retirement
account
count o sea para una cuenta individual
de retiro hay muchos tipos de ira si
está el rol y ya está el set irá y cada
uno tiene sus particularidades la idea
básicamente es que el gobierno te motiva
a ahorrar para tu retiro ahorita en lo
que nos vamos a enfocar es en el día
tradicional y para eso pensemos en la
siguiente situación pensemos que ahora
ahora o sea hoy en día tienes dos
opciones abrir una cuenta irá o no
entonces le voy a poner aquí que aquí es
cuando cuando abrimos la cuenta irá y
aquí es no no irá no
irán muy bien la idea de tener una
cuenta irá es que va a ser metiendo
dinero y el dinero que puedes meter está
limitado número uno por lo que ganas no
puedes meter más de lo que ganas pero
además está limitado por una cantidad
que depende del año y de tu edad déjame
poner acá en 2010 en cuanto estaba para
hacernos una idea en 2010 se podía meter
hasta cinco mil dólares cinco mil
dólares si tenías menos de 50 años menos
de 50 y más y bueno y hasta y hasta seis
mil seis mil dólares y tenías más de 50
años y la lógica detrás es que si tienes
más de 50 años entonces estás más cerca
de retirarte
el retiro es a los 59 años y medio y por
tanto pues deberías de ser capaz de
poder meter más o debería de tener
permitido poder meter más bueno pensemos
que tenemos menos de 50 años y que vamos
a aprovechar al máximo nuestra ira
nuestra cuenta de retiro individual
entonces aquí meteríamos los cinco mil
dólares que podemos meter
y acá como no tenemos cuenta de retiro
individual como no tenemos irá no
metemos nada una primera diferencia así
a corto plazo es que por estos 5000 no
vamos a pagar nada de impuestos así que
para hacernos una idea de la comparación
vamos a pensar que estamos en el rango
en el rango de 32% 32% de impuestos
vale de impuestos entonces como te
comentaba por estos 5000 no se va a
pagar nada de impuestos aquí le voy a
poner 0 no se paga nada de impuestos por
los 5 mil 25 mil dólares que metemos en
este momento no se paga nada pero acá
estos cinco mil pues estos cinco mil si
tenemos que pagarle sus impuestos verdad
del lado derecho entonces hay que pagar
cinco mil dólares
por una tasa del 32 por ciento vamos a
ver cuánto es eso sacó la calculadora
entonces la encendemos
entonces sería cinco mil cinco mil por
punto treinta y dos serían mil
seiscientos entonces acá se pagan
desigual y se pagan mil seiscientos mil
seiscientos en impuestos cuánto nos
quedan pues después de los 5.000
quitarles los 1600 nos quedarían de este
lado tres mil cuatrocientos 3400 de este
lado es efectivo es efectivo lo puedes
usar para lo que quieras de este lado
está en una cuenta especial ahora está
esta deducción de impuestos sólo se
puede hacer por estos cinco mil vale o
sea si ganas en total cien mil cien mil
dólares
entonces aún hay que pagar impuestos por
95 mil dólares en este caso pero acá hay
que pagar impuestos por todos los 100
mil dólares por eso la diferencia
la diferencia es esto que calculamos
aquí lo que estamos pagando de impuestos
por estos cinco mil dólares muy bien
ahora como nos preocupa el futuro pues
en ambas situaciones vamos a realizar
una inversión vamos a invertir ese
dinero
pero ojo acá a la izquierda acá a la
izquierda el dinero está en una cuenta
especial en esa cuenta o bueno de esta
cuenta no podemos retirar el dinero o al
menos no sin consecuencias si nosotros
queremos sacar el dinero para comprarnos
un mercedes benz o algo por el estilo si
queremos gastar lo tenemos que pagar una
penalización y eso es particularmente
importante eso es lo que el gobierno nos
pide a cambio que realmente estemos
ahorrando para el retiro entonces deja
lo escribo entonces si retiramos hay que
pagar penalización pagar penalización
penalización e impuestos e impuestos
finalización e impuestos si se retira y
se retira
antes de la jubilación o sea antes de
los 59 años y medio va entonces bueno
esto es para el ira tradicional en
rodilla tiene un poco más de
flexibilidad con respecto a la cantidad
principal que pones pero básicamente lo
que hay que recordar es que esto es un
incentivo que nos da el gobierno para
que guardemos para el retiro así que si
lo gastamos si lo gastamos tiene una
penalización pero bueno aunque no se
pueda gastar si se puede invertir estos
cinco mil si los podemos invertir
digamos en acciones entonces vamos a
pensar vamos a pensar que estos cinco
mil y estos tres mil cuatrocientos en
ambos casos todo lo invertimos en
acciones de una cierta compañía
entonces compramos cinco mil en acciones
acciones de ohl y acá compramos tres mil
400 3400 en acciones de acciones d
bueno imaginemos que transcurre el
tiempo pasan los años y pues nos va
realmente bien
las acciones de a duplican su precio y
las vendemos entonces de este lado ahora
qué pasaría pues esos cinco mil se
convirtieron en diez mil dólares
diez mil dólares y estos tres mil
cuatrocientos se convirtieron en seis
mil ochocientos bueno seguimos
preocupados por el futuro de halle pongo
que aquí fueron diez años diez años para
que vayamos llegando llevando la cuenta
diez años entonces seguimos preocupados
por nuestro futuro entonces ahora lo que
hacemos es comprar acciones de una
compañía ve vale entonces lo voy a poner
con este color rosa aquí lo que vamos a
hacer es comprar diez mil diez mil 10
mil a esta no me falta un 0 10 mil en
acciones debe en acciones debe
debe y acá también vamos a comprar todo
lo que tenemos en acciones debe pero ojo
aquí ganamos 3.400 que están fuera de la
cuenta irá entonces hay que pagar por la
ganancia de capital hay que pagar
impuestos por esta ganancia de capital
entonces cuando tendríamos que pagar
bueno pues pasaron diez años así que la
tasa no sería tan grande hay que pagar
hay que pagar una tasa del 15% del 15%
por esta ganancia de capital que tuvimos
déjame ver cuánto da eso entonces
prendemos la calculadora 3.400 es unos
400 3400 ok por por punto 15 510
entonces tenemos que pagar tenemos que
pagar 510 dólares 510 dólares por eso
que ganamos entonces cuánto nos quedaría
6 mil 800 menos 510 menos 510
sería seis mil 296 mil 290 dólares
entonces estos seis mil 290 dólares son
los que vamos a invertir ahora en
acciones de 6.290 en acciones y acciones
de ve bueno pasa otra vez el tiempo
pasan otros diez años pasan otros diez
años lo voy a poner aquí diez años y
también diez años y de nuevo vamos a ser
optimistas y pensemos que en esos diez
años se vuelve a duplicar el dinero que
tenemos entonces cuánto nos quedaría de
este lado al vender las acciones ahora
tendríamos en nuestra cuenta irá
tendríamos 20 mil dólares 20 mil dólares
y de este lado de este lado serían el
doble de 6.290 es 12 mil 580 entonces
nos quedarían 12 mil
580 a 12 mil 580 dólares aquí no pagamos
impuestos por esta ganancia que tuvimos
por esta ganancia de capital acá acá si
tenemos que pagarlos entonces vamos a
pagar los impuestos para ver cuánto nos
queda la ganancia fue la ganancia fue de
6 mil 290 por punto 15 otra vez fue una
ganancia de capital a largo plazo vamos
a ver cuánto nos queda entonces sería
prendemos la calculadora 6.290 por punto
15 12 6 943 punto 5 943 punto 5 de una
vez voy a hacer la resta para ver cuánto
me queda entonces 12.580 menos 940 y 3.5
eso nos da 11 mil 636 para entonces aquí
es 940 y 3.5 y 11 mil 636 940 y 3.5 y de
este lado lo que nos queda después de
restar 900 43.53 11011 1600
6 bueno voy a quitar los centavos 11 mil
636 vale aquí sería punto 5 pero bueno
mira entonces aquí ya tenemos estos dos
resultados vale hasta ahorita han pasado
20 años pensemos que ahorita ya podemos
retirarnos ya llegamos a los 59 años y
medio vamos a ver qué sucede en este
momento vale lo que tenemos acá a la
derecha después de que pasaran los 20
años es puro efectivo este efectivo ya
podemos utilizarlo para lo que queramos
para comprarnos un mercedes para el
gasto corriente para lo que sea pero
aquí a la izquierda aquí a la izquierda
pensando en que ya tenemos más de 59
años y medio más de 59 años y medio
entonces ahora sí podemos retirar estos
20 mil sin penalizaciones pero ojo si
hay que pagar impuestos va bueno lo
bueno de ahorita de esta edad es que muy
probablemente estemos en un rango menor
de pagar impuestos porque estemos
ganando menos dinero en general porque
se daría este fenómeno pues mira antes
estábamos así en la juventud éramos
empresarios famosos y exitosos en la
cima de nuestra carrera y por lo tanto
ganábamos mucho y pagábamos 32% acá
abajo ya estamos ganando menos vamos a
vivir de nuestra pensión y por lo tanto
tenemos que pagar menos no sé para
hacernos una idea imaginemos que hay que
pagar 25 por ciento de impuestos 9 25
por ciento de impuestos
y de esta forma lo que hay que pagar de
impuestos por estos 20 mil dólares sería
cinco mil cinco mil dólares muy bien
vamos a ver cuánto nos quedan acá nos
quedan once mil 636 pero de este lado de
este lado en el lado de la cuenta irá
nos quedarían quince mil 15 mil 15 mil
dólares muy bien vamos a comparar qué
pasa de este lado tenemos 15 mil dólares
y de este lado tenemos 11 mil 636 y en
cuanto en en cuanto a inversiones
realizamos exactamente lo mismo invertir
lo más que podíamos en nada y en vez
entonces pues qué sucede acá acá ganamos
más
y decimos buenas inversiones pero pero
estas inversiones se acumularon para
hacer una diferencia grande verdad mira
más o menos de estos 11 mil 636 ganamos
el 30 por ciento más abriendo una cuenta
irá y de hecho o sea nos pudo haber ido
mucho mejor en esta cuenta ir a este 25
por ciento de impuestos este 25 por
ciento de impuestos es algo alto en
realidad casi siempre la gente se retira
teniendo que pagar
vale además de eso logramos postergar
nuestros impuestos hacia el futuro eso
está bueno 20 años después de este lado
tenemos 11 mil 636 y de este lado
tenemos 15 mil dólares acá nos fue mejor
ojo cuál fue el precio que tuvimos que
pagar la liquidez estoy acá verdad
entonces la cosa con la cuenta irá es
que no podíamos tener el dinero a la
mano o bueno si queríamos tenerlo a la
mano teníamos que pagar una penalización